David Boder: [In English] Paris, Paris September...Paris...Paris...Paris, September the 8th, 1946. Bellevue, a home for displaced children. The interview is Ms. Lina Stumachin, 36 years old, a tattoo number from Auschwitz: 26569.
David Boder: [In German] Also Frau Stumachin, wollen Sie wieder anfangen. Da war etwas mit dem Apparat. Wollen Sie uns sagen, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg sich angefangen hat.
Lina Stumachin: Also ich bin, ich war in Zakopane. Dort war ich mit meiner Familie und mit meinem Mann und mit meiner Kind.
David Boder: So, wie alt war das Kind?
Lina Stumachin: Das Kind war dreizehn [unverständlich] Jahre alt, das war das sechste Jahr alt.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Lina Stumachin: In 1939.
David Boder: Im 39. Jahr.
Lina Stumachin: 39.
David Boder: Und Ihre Beschäftigung war was?
Lina Stumachin: Ich habe ein Fotoatelier und ein Fotogeschäft gehabt in Zakopane.
David Boder: Und Ihr Mann?
Lina Stumachin: Mein Mann war da in dieser, in dieser Branche
David Boder: Aha. Wo haben Sie Fotografie gelernt?
Lina Stumachin: Ich war, ich habe bei meinem Mann gelernt. 15 Jahre.
David Boder: Aha. Waren Sie 15 Jahre verheiratet?
Lina Stumachin: Ja, ich bin jetzt 15 Jahre verheiratet.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, also, ist Ihr Mann jetzt hier?
Lina Stumachin: Nein. Ich weiß auch nicht, wo er ist. Ich weiß schon, dass ihm das...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Aha, nun.
Lina Stumachin: Also, im neun, im 40. Jahr sind die Deutschen nach Zakopane und wir mussten evakuieren.
David Boder: Wohin?
Lina Stumachin: Wir sind, wir sind nach Krakau gefahren. Äh, in einen Dorf. In Dorf haben wir ein bisschen gearbeitet und nachher mussten wir ins Ghetto.
David Boder: Aha.
Lina Stumachin: Also im Ghetto sind wir circa ein Jahr waren wir in Ghetto.
David Boder: Wer ist das wir?
Lina Stumachin: Äh, mein Mann, mein Kind und mein Vater und mein Bruder. Alle.
David Boder: Also was war das Ghetto in Krakau. Beschreiben Sie ein bisschen das Ghetto.
Lina Stumachin: Also, das waren, das war äh circa sieben Straßen, mit eine Mauer umgeringt.
David Boder: Ein Mauer oder ein Zaun?
Lina Stumachin: Ein Mauer.
David Boder: War das eine Mauer, gebildet von Ziegeln und Steinen?
Lina Stumachin: Von Ziegeln und Steinen.
David Boder: Wer hat das gebildet, gebaut?
Lina Stumachin: Das haben die Bewohner selbst gebaut.
David Boder: Mit gebaut.
Lina Stumachin: Und dort haben wir gewohnt in einer ganz kleinen, kleiner Wohnung. Und dann, dort haben auch unsere Kinder Todesstrafen [unverständlich] im Ghetto, wir haben Angst gehabt, aber wir konn, hatten nicht viel, keine Möglichkeiten, dass wir dort zu verlassen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, wieso kommt das, dass Sie...[unverständlich] versteht?
Lina Stumachin: In Zakopane hatten wir keine einheitliche Sprache.
David Boder: Zakopane ist was, die Ukraine?
Lina Stumachin: Nein, das ist eine polnische äh Kurstadt.
David Boder: Aha. Wo ist es in der Nähe von welcher großen Stadt?
Lina Stumachin: Das ist 115 Kilometer nach, von Krakau.
David Boder: 115. Wie weit ist es von Katowice, Sosnowice?
Lina Stumachin: Von Katowice circa 140 Kilometer.
David Boder: 140 Kilometer. Und was für ein Kurort war es? Was?
Lina Stumachin: Das war ein Gebirgskurort. Eine Sport...
David Boder: Ein Sportsreservat. Ja. Und wie [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: Also nachher hat man uns ins Lager genommen von, von äh, von der...
David Boder: Ist es besser für Sie, Polnisch zu reden?
Lina Stumachin: Ja.
David Boder: Reden Sie Polnisch, bitte.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Byłyśmy w getcie, później z getta wysłano nas do obozu. Pracowałam na placówce [niezrozumiały].
Lina Stumachin: [In German] Kann ich anfangen in Polnisch und dann alles
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: Ich hab, ich hab schon...
David Boder: Das macht nichts, das wird schon. Also ja, fangen Sie an, aber Sie, fangen Sie an. Wir brauchen nicht zu...
Lina Stumachin: Ah ja.
David Boder: [In Russian] Говорите по польски.
Lina Stumachin: [In German] Von Zakopane an?
David Boder: Ja.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Więc mieszkałam w Zakopanym i miałam tam zakład fotograficzny, razem z moim mężem i z moim dzieckiem żyliśmy we własnym domu. W czterdziestym roku Niemcy stworzyli sobie w Zakopanym dla siebie uzdrojowisko i wszystkim żydom kazali wyjść z Zakopanego. Pozwolili nam zabrać troszkę rzeczy i musieliśmy opuścić nasze miasto. Pojechaliśmy do Krakowa. Obok Krakowa w małym miasteczku mieszkaliśmy tam około niecałego roku. Następnie musieliśmy iść do getta, ponieważ wszyscy...nie było innego miejsca. Nie wolno było żydom mieszkać w innych miastach oprócz getta. W getcie mieszkaliśmy tam około roku, w międzyczasie było kilka wysiedleń także, które ze względu na to, że pracowaliśmy, myśmy przetrwali. Musieliśmy przyjąć placówki przymusowej pracy. Dlatego że kto nie pracował, zostawał wysiedlony. Ażeby zostać z dzieckiem razem, przyjęliśmy pracę w różnych firmach. Mój mąż w jednej firmie, a ja w innej firmie. Następnie zostały placówki skoszarowane, więc zostaliśmy skoszarowani w obozie i byliśmy zmuszoni, zmuszeni zostawić dziecko w domu w getcie. Mieliśmy możliwość odwiedzania dziecka jeden raz w tygodniu. Następnie była likwidacja getta, kiedy przyjechaliśmy w przeddzień likwidacji, zastaliśmy mieszkanie puste, dziecko zostało wywiezione [niezrozumiały] było tak, mówiono, że są obozy dla dzieci, że dzieci są w takich samych obozach jak my i że będzie możliwość zobaczenia je, jak wkrótce wojna się skończy. Pocieszaliśmy się, że się spotkamy znowu razem. Ale bardzo niedługo trwały te złudzenia, widzieliśmy, jak postępowali dalej z tymi dziećmi, wywozili stale z obozów i z gett. Tak, że smutne już było dalsze nasze przeświadczenie. W obozie w Płaszowie byliśmy półtora, nie półtora roku, około roku razem z mężem.
David Boder: [In German] Ich habe nicht in einer Stelle ganz verstanden. Wo ist Ihre Tochter geblieben?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Chodziłam dalej do pracy przymusowej na miasto, to było z korzyścią pewną dla nas, dlatego że z miasta nam można przynosić cokolwiek do jedzenia, a w obozie było bardzo ciężko, bardzo trudno było dostać jakieś wyżywienie, dostawaliśmy bardzo marną zupę i bardzo ciężko było pracować przy tym wyżywieniu. Tak że to, co z miasta przyniosłam, to mogłam pomóc mężowi i także jeszcze innym ludziom dookoła. Ale niedługo to trwało, zamknięto getto, zamknięto obóz i żydzi więcej nie wychodzili na miasto. Byliśmy pewni, że w tym obozie już zostaniemy i tam przeczekamy wojnę, ale stało się inaczej. W roku 1944...zrobiono na nas akcję, nie wiedzieliśmy, co się właściwie z ludźmi ma stać, których brano, okazało się, że ludzi tych wywożono do pracy do Niemiec z Polski. Między innymi byłam i ja wzięta w tym czasie, ale ponieważ nie chciałam wyjechać, a męża zostawić w obozie, uciekłam stamtąd. Kiedy wróciłam do obozu, zastałam męża, który bardzo się ucieszył, że jeszcze wróciłam z tej łapanki. Na drugi dzień chciałam odwiedzić męża, okazało się, że on został w międzyczasie złapany i wywieziono jego właśnie. Od tej pory już więcej męża nie widziałam, do dzisiaj. Z Płaszowa zostałam wywieziona do Oświęcimia. W Oświęcimiu byłam trzy miesiące w okropnej nędzy. Następnie stamtąd pieszo szliśmy do 18, 18 stycznia, podczas najgorszych mrozów, szliśmy do Ravensbricken. W Ravensbricken żyłam, byłam tam 8 tygodni. Nędza nie do opisania, co kroku trupy, przerażenie było ogromne. Nie dostawaliśmy w ogóle jedzenia. Każdy musiał zdobywać. Przyjeżdżały, przywożono kotły, każdy rzucał się na kocioł i kto zdobył, to ten jadł. Kiedy chodziliśmy do...skarżyć się do lagerfürer, to powiedzieli nam [niezrozumiały] i na tym się kończyło. Po 8 tygodniach wywieziono nas do Malhoff. Tam już zupełnie nas głodzono, to było wyraźne, że chcą nas zagłodzić. Przez 8 tygodni ubyło mnie 15 kilo. Ważyłam 39 kilo, kiedy wyszłam z Malhoff. A poza tym inne jeszcze dużo gorzej wyglądały ode mnie. Z Malhoffu wywieziono nas pociągami, jechałyśmy około 3 dni, zupełnie bez jedzenia, aż do Lipska. W Lipsku przyjechałyśmy w okresie najgorszych bombardowań i tam byłyśmy przez kilka dni. Okazało się, że, że to już jest prawie przed ukończeniem wojny i nie pracowałyśmy wprawdzie, ale także nie dostawałyśmy jedzenia. Bardzo, bardzo marne wyżywienie było, tak, że zdawało się, że tam się już na pewno wykończymy. Po kilku dniach jednak wyprowadzono nas na ulice i prowadzono nas tak przez 6 tygodni. Tamśmy chodziły do krążka. Gdzieśmy przychodziły z jednej strony Rosjanie, z drugiej strony Amerykanie, a Niemcy pro...uciekali z nami od frontu do frontu. Po drodze zrywałyśmy różne zielska, ażeby się wyżywić, to było w kwietniu, jeszcze nic nie rosło w polach, ale żywiłyśmy się trawą i wykopywałyśmy kartofle, które dopiero zasadzono. Po drodze spotykałyśmy bardzo dużo wyczerpanych z głodu, trupów, leżących po drogach. Zabijano nas, gdyśmy się odważyły gdzieś podejść, ażeby zdobyć do jedzenia coś. Mimo to żadna się nie bała i każda szła, bo i tak groziła nam śmierć głodowa. Wydawało się, że już w ogóle nie przesta...droga nasza już idzie w nieskończoność. Aż pewnego dnia...bardzo dużo z nas uciekało w drodze, ale myśmy nie wiedziały...Bałyśmy się, że strzelają, bo miałyśmy już doświadczenie. Kto się odłączył od grupy, tego strzelano. Mimo to bardzo dużo ludzi postanowiło oderwać się od pochodu. I pewnego dnia ja z dwuma koleżankami odłączyłyśmy się także i u jednego chłopa znalazłyśmy pracę. Pracowałyśmy tam przez 4 tygodnie. Niemcy już byli dla nas dosyć uprzejmi, bo się bali, bo front przybliżał się coraz więcej [niezrozumiały].
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] [niezrozumiały] W Saksonii zostałam oswobodzona przez Rosjan. Byłam chora, miałam spuchnięte nogi, postanowiłam, że odpocznę, ale tęsknota do domu nie pozwoliła mi usiedzieć. W wyobraźni widziałam już mój dom i że wrócą ci, których straciłam [unintelligible]. Trzeba było iść pieszo. Sto pięćdziesiąt kilometrów szłyśmy pieszo, ciągnąc, ciągnęłyśmy za sobą wózek z wyżywieniem i kilku naszymi łachami, mijaliśmy miasta w gruzach, po drodze spotykałyśmy ludzi, takich samych jak my, szli ku domowi, śpiewali rozradowani pieśni nadziei i myśmy się też cieszyły. 8 maja przyszłam do Krakowa i tam było pierwsze rozczarowanie. Z mojej rodziny, którzy mieszkali w Krakowie, nikogo nie zastałam. Przez 8 dni wałęsałam się po Krakowie, szukając wszędzie, gdzieśmy mieszkali, obeszłam te mieszkania w getcie, gdzie zostawiłam dziecko, myślałam, może ktoś zostawił adres, może ktoś już przyszedł przede mną, ale okazało się, że nikogo jeszcze nie było. Postanowiłam jechać do Zakopanego, ale wszyscy mi odradzali, mówili, że jest niebezpiecznie, że żydzi nie powinni wracać do małych miasteczek, że są różne ekscesy. Jednym słowem, że jeżeli już przeżyłam wojnę, żebym raczej w większym mieście zaczekała, aż wrócą nasi, że na pewno mnie odnajdą. Ale byłam niecierpliwa, chciałam już być tam, myślałam, że może tam poszli, że może czekają na mnie, postanowiłam jednak pojechać. 8 czerwca przyszłam do domu i niestety zdumiona byłam, tam gdzie mój dom stał, był tylko trawnik. Ani śladu z domu. Jakieś kozy pasły się na pastwisku. Zamieszkałam u sąsiadki i dzień w dzień czekałam, czy ktoś wróci. Długie dni i tygodnie wypatrywałam na daremno. Czekałam...aż zmuszona koniecznością, bo nie miałam, bo nie wiedziałam, do czego się wziąć, nie miałam, do czego się wziąć...wyjechałam szukać pracy. Przez 8 tygodni w różny przygodny sposób zarabiałam, ażeby się utrzymać, nie chciałam być na utrzymaniu obcych ludzi. Stale jednak wiedziona tęsknotą wracałam do domu, że może jednak ktoś już tam czeka na mnie, może ktoś wrócił. W międzyczasie stworzył się dom dziecka w Zakopanym, postanowiłam się, postanowiłam poświęcić się pracy przy dzieciach, ażeby zapełnić pustkę mojego życia. Już rok pracuję przy dzieciach i z nimi razem ruszyłam w świat, ażeby może gdzieś w naszej ojczyźnie znaleźć spokój. Rzucali z miejsca na miejsce, może wreszcie znajdziemy gdzieś zakątek, gdzie będziemy mogli spokojniej żyć...wolniejsi...niewyśmiewani...niedręczeni...Gdzie będę mogła patrzyć na przyszłość radośniejszą dzieci, które wyrosną pod moim okiem.
David Boder: [In German] Ich habe nicht in einer Stelle ganz verstanden. Wo ist Ihre Tochter geblieben?
Lina Stumachin: Man hat die Kinder [unverständlich] Auschwitz.
David Boder: Man hat die Kinder aporte genommen?
Lina Stumachin: Es ist so. Wir haben gearbeitet.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter!
Lina Stumachin: Wir haben gearbeitet äh in, bei
David Boder: In einer Fabrik?
Lina Stumachin: Nein, bei Arbeit.
David Boder: Was für eine Arbeit?
Lina Stumachin: Nicht. Wir haben gearbeitet in diese, in deutsche Kaserne.
David Boder: Aha, ja.
Lina Stumachin: Was haben Sie da getan, in der Kaserne?
David Boder: Alle Arbeiten
David Boder: Sauber gemacht?
Lina Stumachin: Sauber gemacht, Hausarbeiten, auf dem Feld gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Lina Stumachin: Wir haben nun
David Boder: Ja. Nun.
Lina Stumachin: Ja, wir waren bei Arbeit sind wir abends zurückgekommen und da haben wir unsere Wohnung leer gefunden.
David Boder: Oh. Un.
Lina Stumachin: Und wir haben nicht gewusst wo Kinder waren, sind geblieben, geworden.
David Boder: Was haben die Leute gesagt?
Lina Stumachin: Sie haben gesagt, dass man die Kinder nach Auschwitz
David Boder: Ja, aber was jetzt? Ist die Polizei gekommen, hat die Kinder weggenommen?
Lina Stumachin: Nein.
David Boder: Wie denn?
Lina Stumachin: Also in Polnisch kann ich Ihnen das sagen.
David Boder: Ja, sagen Sie es mir.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] A kiedy wróciliśmy do domu...
David Boder: [In Russian] Кто это вы?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Ja i mój mąż.
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Myśmy obydwoje pracowali w przymusowej pracy...
David Boder: [In German] Aha.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...poza gettem. Kiedy wróciliśmy do domu, okazało się, że dzieci zostały wywiezione. Więc opowiadano nam, że kazano dzieciom spakować paczki...
David Boder: Dzieciom?
Lina Stumachin: . . . dzieciom, spakować walizki i napisać adresy, gdzie rodzice są, gdzie zawiozą ich do rodziców.
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...No i zapakowali ich na auta i wywieźli, i więcej do tej pory nie wiemy, co się z nimi stało. Mówiono, że...
David Boder: z nimi, z dziećmi?
Lina Stumachin: z dziećmi, co się z tymi dziećmi stało.
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...Ja jedno miałam. Ale było tam dużo dzieci, prawda, w getcie było bardzo dużo dzieci, kiedy nas zabrali. I to było miasto dzieci, bo przecież wszystkich dorosłych zabrali do pracy i później skoszarowali dzieci...y...Skoszarowali nas wszystkich dorosłych w obozach, a dzieci w getcie zostały, był tam taki utworzony „kinderhin”.
David Boder: [In English] There was in the getto a “kinderhin”.
Lina Stumachin: [In German] Ja.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Ale moje dziecko nie było w „kinderhin”, moje dziecko było w domu, u mnie w mieszkaniu, tam gdzie ja mieszkałam przedtem.
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Oni zabrali na auto i wywieźli.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] A z mężem razem pracowałam w obozie...No i...do przymusowej pracy do Niemiec wysyłali, bo już spodziewali się, że, że już będzie koniec wojny...To...zaczęli likwidować obozy w Polsce.
David Boder: [In German] Aha.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...I zaczęli wywozić z obozów w Polsce do obozów w Niemczech.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...Także mój mąż pracował, później po roku dowiedziałam się, że pracował w fabryce w tym...w Pionkach w fabryce amunicji.
David Boder: [In Russian] Да.
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish]...a ja jeszcze stale byłam w Płaszowie. No a po, po roku wywieźli nas też do Oświęcimia.
David Boder: [In German] Ah, was werden Sie jetzt tun, was wollen Sie jetzt tun?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Moje pragnienia nie są sprecyzowane, ale najchętniej trzymałabym się właśnie przy dzieciach, dalej, bo to jest okropne taka samotność, a tak to wypełnia przynajmniej tą pustkę, te głosy dziecięce, i zapomina się w tej pracy o tym, że kiedy miało się swój własny dom, że kiedyś miało się swoją własną rodzinę, że kiedyś miało się swoje własne dziecko.
David Boder: [In German] Und Sie wollen nach Palästina gehen?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Tak. Poszłabym razem z tymi dziećmi, które tutaj są, do Palestyny, żeby razem z nimi żyć dalej.
David Boder: [In Russian] А вы что думаете в Палестине [неразборчиво]?
David Boder: [In German] Palästina werden Sie auch alle die Kinder zusammen behalten?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Byłoby to moim życzeniem, żebyśmy wszyscy razem byli, bo to jest taka przybrana rodzina już dzisiaj. A mam nadzieję jednakże, iż te miesiące, kiedy jesteśmy razem, tak nas związały, że, że przynajmniej niektóre będą się starały tak trzymać się razem przynajmniej, że będą chciały tworzyć taką jedną rodzinę ze sobą. Te dzieci też są samotne, też potracili przecież rodziców i mają pragnienie też mieć kogoś bliskiego koło siebie. Tak że chciałabym z nimi zostać.
David Boder: [In German] Ah, wie viel Jahre ist das kleinste Kind jetzt?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Najmniejsze dziecko tutaj ma trzy latka. Zabraliśmy je przed naszym odjazdem z Zakopanego. Było ich pięć takich po trzy latka. Rozwijają się bardzo ładnie, są takie mądre i słodkie.
David Boder: [In German] Und äh, sind das die Kinder, was Sie nennen Bobolaki?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Tak. To są najmniejsze, te Bobolaki, któreśmy zabrali z klasztoru Boboli, z Zakopanego.
David Boder: [In German] Aha. Äh. Wer hat Ihnen gesagt, dass die Kinder dort sind?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] To nasza kierowniczka się dowiedziała o tym, ktoś jej powiedział, że jest tam pięcioro żydowskich dzieci, które zostały wyratowane z Warszawy, z pożaru.
David Boder: A kto ich ratował...[unintelligible]
David Boder: [German] Wären Sie gern...
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Podobno jakiś policjant je wydostał stamtąd i przywiózł je do klasztoru.
David Boder: [In Russian] Почему полициянты их [niezrozumiały]?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] To my, my tego tak bliżej nie wiemy. Może by kierowniczka...
David Boder: [In German] Was denn?
Lina Stumachin: [In Polish] Może kierowniczka...
David Boder: [In German] Was heißt das denn?
Lina Stumachin: Die Leute, die waren schlecht.
David Boder: Aha, ich mein die Polizisten. Man sagt, die Polizisten waren nicht solche guten Menschen.
Lina Stumachin: Nicht alle, aber manche. Aber manche waren doch menschlich.
David Boder: Was haben Sie getan? Die Kinder rausgebracht und sie weggegeben?
Lina Stumachin: Sie haben sie dort in diesen Kloster reingebracht
David Boder: Reingenommen. Aber sie behaupten. Frau Stumachin, ich hoffe, dass alles jetzt besser wird. Ich danke Ihnen sehr, Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht alles in Polish so gut versteh.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 118...at 29 min, the report of Ms. Lina Stumachin, 36 years old, a tattoo number: 26569. She spoke in Polish.